[Music]
welcome to spin the wheel
where we're going to spin the wheel now
with our 50 members we got the 25
members watching as an audience we're
going to give it a spin and then
whatever it lands on vanity is going to
ask you a question from that board okay
gotcha this guy's all business i like
him
spin it spin it spin it who said it is
the category here is the question mr
james sanders for 100
who said the more biblical verses you
have on your body
the more violent you are as a person
which history nahina's guest
said that or host right no it's just
which
guest which guest said that do you want
us to repeat it or you got it
say it one more time one more time who
said this guy's a ball of fun
who said the more biblical verses you
have on your body the more violent you
are as a person
hell i don't know that sounds like
something you might say all right that's
i thought i did say it but you know who
it is
the one and only dan soder oh my god
that guy's great he is [ __ ] great i
must have missed it well they don't know
nets
uh no it was actually on the episode
from a couple years ago when we talked
about uh the
indian reservations right or history of
the native americans
i was late i was late coming to the
party you did uh
you did uh some of this burning with sal
and burke chrysler that's the first time
i saw you so
there he is dude i'm like a year late
all right brother well you're here now
thank you so much for your for your
membership hope you had a good time on
spin the wheel
and uh yeah what's that
guy you're the bum plug guy wow
[ __ ] yeah dude
you had a particular set of skills yeah
james sanders the bum pug lie
above plug guy you [ __ ] yeah you're a
psycho like buffalo bill
yo i got them for the whole crew and one
for the house so whether you use them or
not i don't care you're gonna have to
what do you have in your ass right now
all of them yeah spin the wheel welcome
to
the new show spin the wheel we're gonna
spin the wheel you've got to answer a
trivia question okay
okay here we go richie g might know this
[ __ ] richard she's the best he's like
he's got real money he's got real money
he's also a funny kid yeah
okay all hyena no history category
for a hundred dollar for 200 we'll go
here with
what is a kamikaze
this is all history or all hyena sorry
this is this is uh
all hyena no history so what is a
kamikaze for the
hyenas it's just whenever um mike's
recording you when you're not paying
attention
yes yeah the first correct answer give
it up for richie g it's almost like we
taylor made that one because it gives us
so much money
we just threw him a softball yeah one
year it's almost like saying what's
chris's name
yeah cause ritchie g is a long time uh
member and thanks for showing us your
house cuz because if the patreon does
take a dip we're gonna come to kansas
city and tie you up and steal your money
yeah let me just tell you something
you know the kid's got real money he's
got his own bar
inside of his apartment and a pool table
yeah yeah
yeah because your house looks like a
[ __ ] starbucks coffee shop
like i said man i moved from dallas to
kansas city so it wasn't it's not it's
not like new york
right but it's still dope yeah oh we're
going to send you a t-shirt so you'll
send us your address or a p.o box
whatever you want we're going to send a
t-shirt
but make no mistake i might show up too
i have to see that apartment
like you're getting something from
wayfair you know we'll save this for
next month
guys that was very fun on spin the wheel
i had a great time great seeing
everybody
yes i'm out of gas and yeah and thank
you
to tony thank you tony
aka sabrina the hyena incredible we
don't even know if we want people to
know we don't know but
incredible incredible work thank you we
love you tony
if you want to be able to ask a question
you need to go up to the 50
tier 25s get you just to be audience in
the building
but if you want to actually ask a
question you got to go up to the 50s and
play the game
um and uh and we're making it better
each time so
you know how it is we love you we love
our fans we just want to give you
everything we can so
appreciate it yeah this is a new show
for the 50 members called spin the wheel
it's going to get wilder as we go this
is the first one thanks for checking in
lisa johnson we're glad that you're okay
good to see you truffle pig
good to see you [ __ ] richie g yeah if
you guys if you guys feel like you know
because the economic hardships
of the pandemic if you don't feel like
you can get to the 25 to 50 on your own
just hit up richie gene he'll get you
there yeah richie cheaple
richie g will lend you the money and the
other kid is making butt plugs
what was his name we're going to ben
sanders dave sanders butt plug steve
thank you so much yeah i love you steve
yeah that guy's gonna yeah
yeah all right love you james